of all the chicanery and shenanigans
that Democrats pulled during the 2020
election perhaps the most Brazen and
significant was big Tech's decision to
censor the hunter Biden laptop story The
censorship was outrageous and dangerous
in and of itself a group of billionaire
oligarchs deciding what could and could
not be presented in the Public Square
before an election
but now the story has gotten even worse
thanks to Mark Zuckerberg's Revelation
on The Joe Rogan podcast that he and
Facebook and big tech only censored the
story
because the FBI told him to
basically the background here is the FBI
I think basically came to us some some
folks on our team it was like hey
um just so you know like you should be
on high alert there was we we thought
there was a lot of Russian propaganda in
the 2016 election we have it on notice
that basically there's about to be some
kind of dump of of um uh that's similar
to that so just be vigilant so our
protocol is different from Twitter's
what Twitter did is they said you can't
share this at all
um we didn't do that the Distribution on
Facebook was decreased but people were
still allowed to share it so you could
still share it you could still consume
it so when you say the distribution is
decreased it got shared how does that
work it basically the ranking in news
feed was a little bit less so fewer
people saw it than would have otherwise
so it definitely by what percentage I
don't know off the top of my head but
it's it's it's meaningful but we weren't
sort of as black and white about it as
as Twitter we just kind of thought hey
look if the FBI which I still view as a
legitimate institution in this country
it's a very professional law enforcement
they come to us and tell us that we need
to be on guard about something then I
want to take that seriously
so Facebook censored the story but
actually only a little bit but actually
pretty significantly but actually Mark
Zuckerberg doesn't remember how much and
it did so because the FBI told it to
little tough to follow the
contradictions and the equivocations but
at the very least Zuckerberg is telling
us that the FBI the allegedly
non-partisan federal law enforcement
agency that had been illegally attacking
Donald Trump since before he even became
president
interfered in the 2020 election to keep
damaging information about the Biden
family out of the Public Square
information so damaging that 17 percent
of Biden voters in swing States
according to one survey said that they
would not have voted for Biden had they
known about the laptop before the
election
would have swung the election to Trump
the Deep State pressured big Tech to
help elect Democrats and kick a
Republican president out of the White
House but remember
if you question our oligarchs you're a
threat to democracy the Democrats
not just the Democrats
the libs
because we're not just talking about the
political party we're talking about the
whole kind of liberal establishment
especially in the bureaucracy but
through all the rest of society too the
libs reward their enemy reward their
allies and punish their enemies that's
how they do politics
and it is pretty much politics 101 it is
pretty much the most basic way of
thinking about politics going all the
way back not just to ancient Greece but
going back to the days of the cavemen
you reward your friends and you punish
your enemies that's how they do this
the way they do this is
before the election the FBI comes
knocking on Facebook they say Hey listen
here listen listen my boss is over there
in Washington DC they sure would
appreciate it if look there's going to
be some information about Hunter Biden
coming out you understand we don't want
that to come out you understand what I'm
saying that would be very unfortunate if
that came out so we're going to just
we're gonna sweep that one under the rug
right right as a nice tech company you
got here sure would be a shame if
something happened to it okay we're good
we're good okay good
that's what they do and what does
Facebook do face first of all Facebook
is just full of Libs and it's part of
the liberal establishment anyway so
they're probably more than happy to
oblige but even if they weren't they're
feeling the force of the government the
permanent government that the
administrative bureaucracy the Deep
State and they're saying okay
I don't want to get on the wrong side of
the FBI don't forget what Chuck Schumer
said
he was in a way making fun of Donald
Trump and in a way he was giving a
warning to everybody in a way I think it
was quite sincere when he said don't go
against the intelligence Community
they'll kill you nine ways from Sunday
they could destroy your life so easily
just don't do it
and that's what happened here
that's what happened that's that's the
same sort of thing you're seeing on the
student debt forgiveness there's not
much of a principle at play here it's
just a political payoff the Democrats
are paying off their friends and
that they're doing that in a very direct
way and then in a less direct way
they're punishing their enemies
the people who who don't go to college
who are less likely to vote for
Democrats the people who are financially
responsible and paid off their student
loans who are less likely to vote for
Democrats those guys are going to now
have to foot the bill for the people who
are getting the Free Ride
even among the staffers of the White
House
regular politics Philip Wegman just
reported that at one in five White House
staffers currently has student debt at
least 30 senior White House officials
have outstanding student loan balances
this is according to financial
disclosures representing one in five of
the staffers who are required to file
the documents
and so Biden's giving a handout to his
friends
and he's punishing his enemies and
maybe Republicans should learn a little
lesson from that
you know Republicans
they're so eager to prove that that
they're really neutral and they're
really high-minded and they're really
above politics
the conservatives are so eager to do
that that's what the never Trump
movement was the never Trump movement
was listen I don't I don't support all
this tribalism I don't support these
Party politics I mean this is you always
hear the the squishes in almost every
election you'll have some moderate
Republican who comes out and he says Ah
look I'm a republican but I'm going to
break with my party country before party
which isn't it a meaningless statement
you join a party because you think it'll
help your country you think it's the
best thing for your country so country
before parties is a distinction without
a difference but they do it because what
they're really saying is look I'm not
I'm not just going to help my friends
and punish my enemies no no I'm above it
all I'm at frankly I'm fairer to my
enemies than to my friends that's how
high-minded it is and that's how you
lose that's how you lose at politics
that's how the libs take over the whole
culture for the past 60 years
maybe conservatives should learn a
little bit of a lesson from the lips we
shouldn't do things that are unjust we
shouldn't do things that are immoral
which the libs often do
but I think we can engage in regular
normal politics where you have alliances
and you help out your constituents and
you don't just constantly cave in to
your opponents I'm glad you like that
clip now look we hit a million
subscribers on YouTube I appreciate that
that's really great that we did it now
we gotta hit a billion a trillion a
quadrillion who knows sky's the limit
ring the bell subscribe we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]